hard to believe situation at a high
school in New Hampshire after a lunch
lady says she was fired for giving a
student a free lunch worth only eight
dollars bonny Kimball says she was
accused of theft by the food vendor and
also claims she asked a team to pay his
debt which was settled the very next day
two workers quit and protests but the
food provider says the information
provided and reported is untrue although
they didn't really specify I love lunch
ladies Gregg all right you know what I
mean I am going to take a unpopular
stance on this because I don't really
believe the story completely she should
have gotten in trouble and by the way
eight bucks is a lot of money only eight
bucks is a lot of money look talk to any
bar owner or watch any episode of bar
rescue the thing that kills a business
is people giving away free booze paid
back it's easy for just trying to make
an argument bartender to be generous if
he doesn't pay for the booze so she
wasn't giving away her food she was
given away the school's food she should
be arrested and put away for just ten
years live lock her up and the child
needs to go away to camp a summer camp
they have a different point of view here
feel for her and and also for the boy
right because it's not easy if you and
if you're broke right and but what I do
think is interesting she she took that
risk she allowed him to do that and then
if you do that you often do get paid
back she'd be paid they paid it back the
next day one I wonder if it was one of
those Michelle Obama lunches because
those aren't even worth $1 I love how
you brought the Obamas into this mystery
meat are like no meat one of those
things everyone hated them I don't know
I didn't go to the cafeteria but you
know I just felt for her and I noticed
that two of her colleagues quit in
support of her but then it part of the
story is that the food service had a
competitor come in and was looking at
the school that day and they were
worried that the school district was
going to give the business to them I
knew there was going on yeah that's a
good point what about you digging this
is what we are these days we punish good
people tater tots forever I don't I love
tater all right